so I understand Earl that originally you
did not want to play in giant can you
tell us that story and how you came to
be in this film I'm so lucky that I
changed my mind what happened was I had
been in a film called broken Lance I
played one of spencer tracy's sons and
when George was looking for locations to
shoot where they would shoot make the
Rihanna ranch they were looking at the
broken Lance and I got a call from my
agent who said that they've gotten a
call from an aide of George's and while
looking at the picture he had pointed to
me on the screen he said when we do
giant I want to use that boy so I think
was my god I was I was hysterical I was
so pleased I was delighted and I ran out
and I got the book and I read it cover
to cover and they had missing the role
of Bob dace and in the book Bob dace is
mentioned twice the first time when he's
four years old and he's out for those of
you I don't know how many of you know
what Mountain Oysters are anyway he's
not picking up mountain oysters and the
other time there's another mention of
him too at the end of the book but I
said I was sort of supporting because I
loved the book but actually there's no
part I told the agent that I said just
thank mr. mr. Stevenson did tell him I'd
just would love to work for him but
that's there's no part well in the
meantime they went to Virginia to do the
exteriors back there and then when they
came back to the interiors of Virginia
before going to Marfa Texas I got a call
for the agent said that George Stevens
wanted me to come out to Warner Brothers
and talk to him he was on the set
shooting the interiors of giant and I
said once again I said I said oh please
you know it's just so embarrassing to
have to go there and tell him I don't
want to do the picture you know there's
no part and they said just go just honor
him and go and so I did I went out and
they were shooting that they were lining
up one of the scenes of the dinner table
you know one of those famous scenes back
and we're real Isabel's Rockoff or talks
about Mexico or
and it was one of those things so as
they broke and took time to light the
set he motioned to me to follow him
outside we walked around the whole
soundstage the exterior the sensation
before I had a chance to say anything he
said to me he said I see him as kind of
a Booth Tarkington character I got my
attention
he said he's you know kind of a [ __ ]
kicker you know excuse me but that was
what he said but anyway I I gotta tell
you by the time I came back he just saw
a lot of me when we got back I would
have done anything with this man I just
fell in love with him he it was a
wonderful wonderful human being